it's just a PowerPoint clicker right but
what we worked on was a scheme whereby
this the nurse in the room who's not
scrubbed in the so-called circulating
nurse uh could use a clicker standing by
the patient with the anesthesiologist
and the surgeon and the scrub
nurses and lead a checklist process
electronically on a board at the foot of
the patient on the wall just by
clicking and when they're done the
system pushes that data into the system
record into the
EHR so we've created something that's
both engaged and real in terms of
everyone focusing on the patient at that
moment the way the whole industry agrees
should happen yet is actually easier to
do than treating it as yet another thing
to
document welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get
started 20 minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctec
[Music]
Jeff Robbins welcome to 20-minute
leaders thank you so much for joining at
my speaker series in firesight chats
with with awesome entrepreneurs
innovators and investors uh very excited
to sit with you and get to know your
perspective and get to know your journey
and your story in these 20 short minutes
um and the would love to kick things off
with you know you you've you've spent
many many years in your company that
you've that you've been part of uh um
and um you're helping shape the the
health industry you're talking about the
integration of software Healthcare the
experience of patients during what I saw
on that I very much liked on your
LinkedIn page the perhaps one of the
most important days of their lives and
so very curious to hear about both the
founding story but also a little bit
about the paino in the space and what
you've experienced and acknowledged in
the in this healthc care space and so
tell me a little bit about you know what
are we even talking about what is this
problem that we're
in uh sure um let's let's Jump Right In
uh first of all name is Jeff Robbins I'm
founder and CEO of live data company I
founded in 1991 so when you said been at
this for a while you are
correct and the the problem that's
really first of all that we really only
became aware
of partway through this journey with
live data uh live data established
itself actually first as a as a small
respected and trusted leader and
real-time middle wearer on the uh
electric power grid and we were talking
pre-recording about cyber security and
that was one of our um kind of facets of
our middleware was how do you uh help
the industry uh move data back and forth
in real time uh reliably yet secure
securely uh due to some
uh you know hard to avoid talking about
a personal tragedy in my life uh I
pivoted the company from that uh real
time utility middleware to healthcare I
I lost my middle son Eton who was uh
eight 18 years old freshman in college
he had epilepsy he was a freshman and
died at college and
unexpectedly and it threw my life upside
down and you know obviously this is a
hard thing to hear and talk about and I
don't want to dwell for your listeners
viewers but when you look at the things
that shape and entrepreneurs life it
always comes back to the
personal you know something's going to
drive you and I determine then that I
needed to do something as definitive as
I could in the health care space to try
to improve something about healthc care
I'm not an epilepsy expert I'm not a
doctor um nor a scientist but um having
worked my whole career in uh real-time
data
integration uh as I mentioned the secure
reliable flow of information focused on
machine to human human to machine it it
became logical to try to apply this
expertise if I could to the to the
healthc care space and surgery seemed
the most right
for uh something like what we're with
picturing in that there's a lot of
different moving parts coming together
in that operating room uh in terms of
different
doctors and nurses technicians equipment
obviously the patient patient has to be
ready for surgery what does that mean
where you're an outsider all those
things are like oh who oh very
complicated thing and it turns out it's
not just because we're Outsiders uh it
is complicated there's there are a lot
of moving Parts uh high performance
hospital today is really doing something
very complicated and often in a certain
unex expectedly sad way uh with a
deficit of modern software
tools to facilitate that journey and
when I say deficit I I have a background
as I said in other forms of industrial
process control other Industries started
out of manufacturing went to electric
power I've seen the way in which uh
process control tools help other
Industries and for various I'd say good
reasons they it's been slower to to
surgery and so that was that was the
initial kernel of the idea is how can we
bring uh software into the mix not as
another burden not as more data
entry what what you'll often see right
now in the hospital is very important
well-intentioned uh efforts to add more
recordkeeping right because data
collection's good right if you can
collect enough data you can study the
data and then you can start improving
the process but unfortunately lot of the
data being collected is by typing so so
people went into healthc care wanting to
help people were like wow so I'm going
to spend more of my day typing to help
people which you know there's a logic to
it it's not perverse but it's it's
disappointing if your focus was always
on the people's side and so part of what
we focused on was how are we going to
reduce the amount of mayo entry how are
we going to automate data collection
we're going to
instrument this complex Journey from the
first meeting in a consult with a
surgeon where you might decide to have
surgery through the process of tests and
workups and things getting you ready to
showing up in the right place at the
right time without having eaten or
whatever the instructions were day of
surgery getting you through that
surgical case smoothly making sure the
room's ready before the patient even in
the room so that that when the patient's
there and obviously more exposed you're
in one of those you know little paper
things or whatever and the
room you know the longer you're out
under anesthesia without anyone doing
anything to you the worse it is for
everyone so so the goal was to get the
patient in there totally ready have the
room totally
ready and then help the
team with automation to focus on the
patient and the care and not on the call
it the note taking or
bookkeeping so that that was the
vision now yeah now when you when you
set out this Vision live data was
already operational in another domain
right correct we were operational in
electric power domain and as an
entrepreneur I had to make some
decisions about what to do about all
this and so I decided uh we would
actually sell that division
as our goal and double down if you will
in the health care piece as part of that
pivot point in my
life and and so I recruited someone I
knew from our community here in the
Boston area a great guy who um came in
and ran that division as
a division of live data uh and built it
up to the point where we we were able to
successfully sell it to
Oracle which we did right at the
beginning of the
pandemic which was a you know everyone
was sort of figuring out well we're all
working from home you know especially
the very sophisticated law for orical
news you know they they were having to
adjust their practices to you know being
from H
is I think everyone did a really good
job of of adapting and and so we sold
that Division and uh F and now Focus
exclusively on our Surgical
product if now if we if we look at this
the the world of Health Care and
obviously you're you've become very
intimate with it and you're you
understand not just the technological
complexity but you it sounds like you
have a great deal of respect for for the
human aspect of it right you you
mentioned a few times and and it really
resonated across the screen how you're
how respectful you are of the experience
of the patient throughout this and that
your job from the software end is to
augment their experience and to to Aid
them and and in the in in this in the
you know hopefully you know good and
peaceful transition
um how do you then bring software into
this complicated world I mean highly
regulated highly under served perhaps it
sounds like from what you were observing
how yeah it doesn't sound that easy to
integrate well I guess I get to P myself
on the back you know it's very hard well
it actually is pretty hard I I think I
think it was harder than I could have
imagined um I quick quick background for
those who just to give you a few
conceptual things to for my answer okay
but like the primary dominant software
package in the hospital or surgery
center is the electronic health record
or
EHR and over the last 10 plus years
there's been a lot of money and
attention paid to um getting hospitals
onto an electronic health record off the
paper chart onto a system uh the
government got to Bow the federal
government uh created a reimbursement
incentive schemes to help the industry
move forward uh you know where where
capital is often tight Believe It or Not
despite the huge percent of the GDP we
spent on Healthcare it's uh hospitals
run on lean
margins um and and so that system of
record is now pretty well
ensconced and so part of finding a way
in for us was to realize well the the
indust other Industries have learned
that there's a notion of a system of
Engagement that sits on top of a system
of record and lets you do some of the
more people Centric
processes uh that don't
replace the vital recordkeeping which
serves many different Regulatory and
risk and other interests but let you add
things quicker to serve the human side
of the equation and The Human Side can
be both patient and and
staff and staff satisfaction in today's
world is also quite vital if you're
concerned with patient satisfaction
because you need to have sufficient
staff to take care of those patients and
they have to feel like they're being
given the support they deserve by their
institution uh to get the job done
properly so that system of Engagement
was the
conceptual round ho we want to fit
around peg into and and
then we we focused on specific areas in
the surgical workflow now this gets
specific to us
where uh we we perceived
um opportunities to really make an
improvement so one area we focused on is
the safe surgery
checklist um we actually started working
on an electronic checklist system before
at tul Gand and others from the briam
the World Health Organization did the
safe surgery checklist
study that provided strong evidence for
the really important usefulness of
checklist in in surgery and for people
not familiar the basic idea of this kind
of checklist is it's a lot like in the
airline industry the idea is hey before
we take off or before we take a knife to
this human body in front of
us we make sure some Basics are really
all set and known do we know who the
patient is do we know which side of the
body we're operating on do we know about
any significant allergies that might
make a tool in appropriate um or
technique and this kind of checklist um
can be done many different ways all you
really need is a piece of paper and
people committed to
stopping and doing it but I realized
that given the uh onslaught of
recordkeeping there was an opportunity
to do the checklist electronically in a
in a way that was
simpler than having a nurse in the room
typing into the the
record and um I didn't play my
yeah sorry it's a product thing I don't
know if you can see this yeah yeah got
it yeah it's just a PowerPoint clicker
right but what we worked on was a scheme
whereby this the nurse in the room who's
not scrubbed in the so-called
circulating
nurse uh could use a clicker standing by
the patient with the anesthesiologist
and the surgeon and the scrub Nur
nurses and lead a checklist process
electronically on a board at the foot of
the patient on the wall just by
clicking and when they're done the
system pushes that data into the system
record into the
EHR so we've created something that's
both engaged and real in terms of
everyone focusing on the patient at that
moment the way the whole industry agrees
should happen yet is actually easier to
do
than treating it as yet another thing to
document and so we moved it from
document to
doing reduce the amount of time it takes
to do the documenting part increase the
you know obviously you can't get inside
the heads of but we believe increased
the uh meaningful execution of the
checklist and and it's been uh we've
been our system's been observed now at
several hospitals by Joy commission
surveyors when they survey the surgical
practice and it's been uh written up um
as a best practice which we're very
proud of well you don't get any Prize or
extra money or something but you know
back to the entrepreneurial
motivations you know one of them is are
we G to make a difference and so that
was our moment when we realized we were
no longer just reasonably smart software
people with our noses pressed up against
the window looking in and we were we're
actually part of the space doing
something useful and that kind of
snowballed into other things we've been
doing in that surgical Journey from way
before the day of surgery to the day to
after and uh that's that's what we're
all about I I I would I would add to
that patient safety
story that part of the thing we're doing
to help the hospital and the staff is
we're trying to help make the sometimes
opaque Hospital Systems easier for
surgeons in the community we're often
wondering hey can I bring my patient to
this hospital this Tuesday or next
Tuesday they might be sitting in a
clinic with you and try to schedule you
know and figure out what's available
when and that kind
of inside the hospital outside the
hospital flow you know sure if every
surgeons an employee of the hospital
they just look they just go into the one
EHR together but plenty of time
in in the US we've got you know private
practices they're not
necessarily uh privileged to go
permission to go look into the HR that
way and so we provided them a really
easy way to do that with our software
which again the same rules of engagement
then pushes the data into the EHR so
we're not breaking Hospital workflow
we're augmenting it and in effect making
it easier to do business with theal
hospital and that is good for patients
because it means every last available
minute is now available so you're you're
booked for surgery sooner and it's more
assured when and what time and will it
really start on time and all that stuff
so so there's kind of a whole lean
process involved here of if everything's
run properly it's both more efficient
and yields better Financial results
and it's also safer as things are
runting in a reproducible correct
way well what this is this is um so so
cool and and so fascinating um and your
your your personal um respect and uh
commitment to this space and to making a
difference it really comes through what
has been the number one most fulfilling
or inspiring piece for you in this in
this
journey well um you there are a lot of
different impacts
um that I felt personally I I would say
the most proud thing for
us
is we we started selling at the Veterans
Administration VHA health
system and at this point we've
sold um with an excellent partner uh do
DS in Florida we've we've we've sold 100
VA hospitals our
solution and you know going from again
that sense of wanting to make a
difference to knowing that we're
impacting for the good the care of so
many US veterans is really been a source
of of
Pride Jess I um want to thank you for
the time and for the uh privilege and
honor of letting me hear this and share
this with the world I really appreciate
it and um you know you talked about the
entrepreneurial Journey a few times and
I think that you really
exemplify and the uniqueness of the
Journey of being able to take something
that you're personally so passionate
about and excited about and bringing it
to the World pivoting the company you
needed and doubling down what you truly
care about and then committing to making
a difference by actually being there and
being on the court and acknowledging
where where the pitfalls are and where
the the difficulties are but doing them
and winning and so I think that that's
just a great great great perspective and
a takeway year for me so Jeff I really
want to thank you and continue
continuing best of luck with live data
and with everything you're doing and
continue making a positive impact on
everything you're involved with and
thank you very much and Michael thank
you very much this has been a pleasure
[Music]